[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
dark brandon takes aim
at wall street
and the maga republicans
they're going to freak out today manga
republicans are going to be
again
all day long all night long for the rest
of the week
talking about how working americans are
such pieces of [ __ ] they've been saying
it for weeks all these lazy americans
who went to college and took student
debt to get ahead those lazy pieces of
[ __ ]
now this morning they're upset that joe
biden
said that wall street did not build this
country working people did which is the
[ __ ] truth
just again
joe biden dark brandon rising just
speaking the [ __ ] truth
and there's nothing they can do about it
as he takes aim at manga republicans
who absolutely in the last week have
been [ __ ] all over working people in
this country by saying oh they're just
lazy
for getting their college debt
taken away and their elites by the way
lazy elites
the majority of people that will
actually apply for this debt relief this
ten thousand dollars which will barely
cover the interest in most of these
loans in the first place
most of those people make under 75 000 a
year you cannot apply if you make over
125 000 i mean you can't apply but you
won't get it
elites
they're saying elites
and now this morning joe biden
dark brandon really
because we've seen a change in the
messaging from the white house and from
democrats and they really should not
relent they should not let up on this
they should really lean into this
telling
america who manga republicans are they
know who they are
they're that [ __ ] idiot down the
street that won't take down this 15
flags in his yard and his it got it he's
got the trump cardboard cut out in his
front window
he's got a thousand trump bumper
stickers he's a cult member he won't
shut the [ __ ] up
when you go to the grocery store it's
the person in the [ __ ]
in the goddamn american flag shorts and
the trump hat that won't shut the [ __ ]
up
we know who these people are we know
what they're about we know what their
agenda is
and it's to take away our way of life
it's to take away our democracy
they want to make america white only
again is what they want
that's what they want
and the easiest way they see to do that
is fascism that's that's why they're
manga republicans
not semi-fascism fascism they're nazis
they're america first nazis i'm gonna go
one step further than dark brandon
because you know i don't i don't give a
[ __ ]
we have to call these [ __ ] fascists
out for who they are
and if we can get the american people to
realize what is at stake in this
election
then maybe maybe just maybe democracy
will work because i believe in democracy
i know you do my audience still believes
in democracy
it's it's really the
most efficient way to equality and
equity
the problem is democracy is really
difficult
it's hard it's not easy it's not easy to
get a lot of diverse people to agree
on a certain set of policies it's not
it's not easy to get there takes a long
time and a lot of work
so authoritarianism is easy you just get
one dumb [ __ ] one buffoon down
in south florida to tell you what to
think boy that's easy then you know what
to think all you gotta do is go over to
his fraud social and know what you're
supposed to say
that's easy [ __ ]
that's easy
if the maga republicans think that the
messaging from joe biden the president
united states this morning from his
twitter account
is tying the maga republicans to wall
street
that wall street is not the people who
built this country
wall street is not the [ __ ] backbone
of this country you want to know who the
backbone is and they know it they
[ __ ] know it it's the people who work
in the goddamn grocery stores who work
in the walmarts who work in the
hospitals
who drive cabs who do construction
that's the [ __ ] backbone of this
country who make products in factories
who drive amazon delivery trucks for
nothing
that's the [ __ ] backbone of this
country the people who work
the people who use their labor who trade
their labor that is what built this
country
joe biden knows it
hell even the manga republicans know
that [ __ ]
and this all in contrast
to the former guy committing espionage
and
and him and his lawyer sydney powell
going to coffee county georgia and doing
exactly
what they are accusing democrats of
doing oh the projection is nah
it's just beautiful
that all the crimes that they committed
they projected on the people who didn't
commit them
it's beautiful
what a contrast
what a contrast i believe joe biden is
doing a damn good job of making the
american people make a choice do you
want autocracy
do you want fascism
or do you want your way of life and you
want to continue with democracy
and have a say in how the shit's run
there has been no modern president
that has taken more money
from the rich
wall street
entered office and told them to go [ __ ]
themselves and did [ __ ] for the american
people that's that's one of the talking
points this morning
from these mogalodites
that's the talking point this morning is
that oh joe baden took more money from
wall street than trump did
and you think the american people are
pissed off that he took money from wall
street because wall street knew trump
would destroy this country
he would destroy the economy that's why
they picked joe biden wall street that
is
you you think the american people are
going to be mad that joe biden took wall
street's money to win an election and
then got into office
and is now working hard for the american
people you think that's gonna piss the
american people off
nothing could be better than a
politician [ __ ] taking money from the
rich people in this country getting in
the office and telling them to go [ __ ]
themselves i work for the american
people
how don't they see this how do how
doesn't anyone see this
this is liberalism folks
that's what this is
this is joe biden
using liberal western democracy
to tell the platocracy of wall street
and the one percent to go [ __ ] off
you're if you're if you're in the
platocracy the one percent joe biden
saying if you're not for the american
working family you're with the fascist
that's what he's saying this morning
he's drawing lines
and it seems some are willing to play
footsie with the fascist
even cnn is willing to play footsie with
the fascist
but that's the price of freedom folks
that's the price of independence that's
the price of liberty
and you have the opportunity you have
the choice to engage in your democracy
that is what is afforded to us by
liberty and yes i know some people are
going to say all the votes rigged
they're trying to rig my vote they're
trying to steal my vote
so that means you're not going to engage
in your democracy you're not going to
engage to try to save it
does that mean does that mean the all or
nothing strategy is going to win i don't
think so
and that is the other thing that the
administration is signaling here is that
we are with the american working
families
that's who we're with we're with you
regardless regardless of who you voted
for we're with you
because when he says maga republican he
doesn't mean people who voted for trump
that's not what he means
you know what he's talking about when
he's talking about manga republican he's
talking about the cult members
and there's plenty of republicans as he
put some conservatives which i don't
even believe those people are
conservative
but there's plenty of republicans out
there you're reagan-style republicans
you're never trumpers
who may have voted for him because they
couldn't stomach hillary clinton may
have voted for him because he couldn't
stomach joe biden whatever or just
didn't vote
but i believe after january 6 and i
believe after
the overturning of roe v wade
and dobbs
and i believe now that
the evidence is showing that donald
trump is a [ __ ] lying criminal
and he will continue he'll never stop
being a lying criminal this is just
seems to be a pattern oh
who'da thunk it who'da thunk
that his lifestyle and his entire life
he was a [ __ ] crook and that he would
continue to be a crook oh my god you're
saying you'll never change no
he's a [ __ ] crook
and he puts our national security and
our economy in danger
and anyone who supports him who gets
into power
will do the same they will put our
national security
and our economy in danger
because they don't give two [ __ ] about
the american working people they don't
give two
[ __ ]
the american working family is not of
their priority
it is only the rich platocracy it is
only the one percent that fill their
pockets
to run around the country fear-mongering
into fascism
because they want full control
they want a plutocracy
they want to control you they want to
control what you do
and they're not hiding it anymore
and joe biden has made wall street make
a choice are you with maga
are you with the american working people
because wall street is nothing without
the american working people not a
goddamn thing
we know that from the pandemic and i
think a lot of americans
woke up and understood
why
why
wall street relies on
us why wall street relies on the in the
workers in the in the retail stores
why wall street relies on the workers in
the restaurants
why they rely on the people in the
factories
and the distribution centers
i think the american people understood
that hey
we we don't owe them anything
they're the ones who owe us for our
labor
for our work
because we're the ones who make them
money on our backs
not anyone else's
and that's what joe biden is saying
and the republicans the manga
republicans are going to go on a tirade
this week against the american working
family
doubt me
doubt me
they're already starting this slog that
joe biden is somehow the the
the most wall streety president ever in
the history because he took money from
wall street yeah but he's doing the
opposite of what they
want quote
so
if you think if you think that this is
another miscalculation from dark brandon
you are out of your mind
because frankly joe biden the president
united states has more more [ __ ]
experience in the political body and
politics in this country
than just about anyone who's in his
administration and the prior
administration he's got more goddamn
experience in politics and his [ __ ]
pinky
than the last administration
and he's patient
he's patient and he does his job
he knows what the work is he knows what
the assignment is
and yeah he may not be the greatest
speaker
he may not be the youngest guy on in the
planet
but the guy is patient
he's steady
he brings stability to the american
people
and when dark brandon kicks in he does
not [ __ ] around
and be quite honest
he's setting you up for success
for our democracy
all you have to do is engage now
he's giving you every single piece of
engagement that you need
every single piece of it because i hate
to be uh
debbie downer here but we're not going
to see indictments before this election
we are way too close
and we're not going to get indictments
out of georgia or new york
florida
d.c
the cases that are not already ongoing
the department of justice and any
prosecutor anywhere is probably not
going to appear to make this political
so that they can't use that as fodder up
for their defense
because they want to make sure when they
have a case that they have the best
defense
and they do not want to have
these maga republicans using politics as
the excuse and the defense
and yes it's dangerous it's a risk
but we can not let them get away with
these [ __ ] crimes
we cannot
and if that means holding just holding
just a bit just a bit
to make sure
that we slam dunk these
folks
so
want to get to this video
of coffee county have you seen this
thing
have you seen this this coffee county
video we're gonna watch it today of
these people going into this election
office and then it appears as this
election official is on the phone
with sydney powell's
i don't know i t person or some [ __ ] i
don't know what the hell this is
i have no idea
i have no idea who this person is and
apparently there's some other
mongoloidites that go down to coffee
county now coffee county apparently is a
very very very trumpy area
but they went into the county office
unannounced unscheduled right this isn't
like it was you know during a time and
actually it was it was january 7th
2021 apparently which is the day after
the insurrection
when their violent attempt to overthrow
the election didn't work it seemed like
they were still grasping at straws
and it appears that the voting machines
were tampered with that same very day
that those that the i.t person
went into the county election office
so the very thing that the trump
allies giuliani
sidney powell lynn wood mike
flynn donald trump donald trump jr all
the big lie
that somehow these michael lindell jesus
christ of my pelo nazis been freaking
out
for two [ __ ] years he's had two big
cyber symposiums
about evidence that was gonna
automatically overturn the election and
donald trump was gonna be crown king or
some stupid [ __ ]
i don't know
but here we have evidence that these
people were [ __ ] with the very
machines that they say democrats were
[ __ ] with not only tina peterson
excuse me colorado you guys remember
this story tina peters lauren bobert's
good friend
is indicted on federal charges for
[ __ ] with voting machines now it
looks like
in georgia
there's going to be charges for them
tampering with voting machines and it's
probably going to turn into a federal
case it's like lindsey graham and rudy
giuliani and these others are [ __ ]
not not wanting to participate in
georgia because they do not want to be
dragged into
a [ __ ] federal case here
because this georgia thing stinks to
high heaven
of course it hands from the very
beginning when brad rathersberger
released the [ __ ] phone call that
trump was extorting them for [ __ ]
votes to change the vote to change the
votes
to defraud the voters in georgia
i watched the video yesterday
and i i i want to reach out to him
rick riley he's a sports writer he's
played golf with trump bill clinton rudy
giuliani um and several professional
golfers and he wrote a book a while back
called the commander in cheat
and i watched a video of him yesterday
talking about how trump cheats on the
golf course
and to be quite honest
it really feels similar to the big lie
a lot of similarities with how he cheats
on the golf course and really it feels
feels really similar
when it comes to the russian collusion
and it almost feels like to me
that it's trump's mo hmm
very interesting
but with these top secret classified
government documents that he stole
from us it seems like if you draw that
same pattern
you could definitely draw conclusions to
why
why are them folders empty
why did you take this [ __ ] why didn't
you want to give it back why haven't you
given it back why are you still
obstructing
why are you still trying to delay the
process if you're so [ __ ] innocent
and these are so declassified
why well if you go back to his
tendencies and this interview or this
this talk
that rick riley gave on the book the
commander in cheat
it really does spell out what happened
in georgia
it really does spell out what they tried
on january 6th
it really does spell out with these fake
electors
what they were trying to do
and now with the top secret documents
being stolen harbored obstructed
used for espionage it seems
it really does spell out what is
happening because that's one thing we
know about trump is he is totally
predictably
unpredictable
you can totally predict
how much of a [ __ ] buffoon he is
and his followers his maga republican
followers are the exact same way
and that's what joe biden is doing he's
setting the trap for them this morning
he set the trap for trump last week
trump fell right into the trap
he's setting the trap for the maga
republicans this week they are going to
fall right into the trap and we must we
must amplify
we must amplify
when they fall into the trap i have a
special person here today you know who
it is texas paul it's tuesday
we've got texas paul here on tuesday
so stick around we're going to talk to
texas paul he's got he's got some big
stories for us that's happening not just
in texas but also around the country
with some of this uh christianity in the
schools and in our legislators um
they're really trying to elbow their way
into chris uh these christian
nationalists are really trying to elbow
their ways into power and control all
around the country not just controlling
the the the school boards and the
legislators but even controlling what
you see and what you do
and they're doing it in really weird
kind of ways they're really
they're trying some some weird strategy
i think here and texas ball has kind of
got some information on that so let's do
this let's go to a break as soon as we
come back we will bring on the midas
mighty favorite texas paul stick around
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
i've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever i try it never
sticks so when babel made a mag edition
i knew i had to give it a try babble mag
edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon i was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that i'm struggling with i
chose babble mag edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now i can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking around through the break
it's tuesday you know what tuesday is
here at the johnny michael's [ __ ] is
tuesday is tacos and texas paul i love
taco tuesday
i i love more than anything
texas fall tuesday
it's the best of the best of the best
texas paul how are you this morning
you're you're muted there you're muted
there's
you're muted there texas ball
i'm pissed off as a raccoon with a
jalapeno shoved up his butt i'm telling
you what i saw here i saw your video
yesterday you were in the cousin pond it
sounds like you might still be there
i'm telling you this is this is this
ain't right this ain't right so let me
ask you well let me ask you real quick
because i know you're a labor guy i know
you're you're a union guy and yesterday
was a labor day and joe biden gave a
speech so i and i know you've got a lot
of stuff you want to talk about with
these christian nationalists but i
really want to get your take um because
we watched part of the speech live
yesterday but i've been excited to talk
to you today about this and i don't mean
to step on your christian nationalism
thing but i i really i really want to
ask you um what did you make of the
speech yesterday but more when joe biden
really set the trap for um the manga
republicans the fascists in this country
this morning when he basically said wall
street is not what built this country
it's the working people he's sending a
trap here with his speech yesterday and
then this tweet today but but labor day
is an important day in this country oh i
lost him
i lost texas paul he'll be back don't
worry we'll get it back so what i was
what i was going to ask texas paul and
i'll ask him again when we get on here
is that i really want to know
um
because labor is an important part of
this country it's the backbone of this
country and really unions are the
backbone of labor
now the the right to organize your labor
and the right to negotiate your labor
has brought us things like the five-day
week the 40-hour week
it's it's brought us a lot of things
something's good something's bad i think
one thing it did to us that i think had
unintended consequences
was workplace insurance i really think
that that is an unintended consequence
that they could not foresee when health
care and the expense of insurance was
less back then i think we got texas paul
back now texas paul are you there yeah
sorry about that i don't know what the
heck happened well it happens it happens
but i wanted to ask you a question about
labor in general and unions as well like
i was saying when you're getting back on
here
unions are really the
labor is the backbone of our country and
unions are the backbone of labor and the
reason why is because the unions are the
reason why we have the 40-hour week we
have the five-day week a work week and
the other things some things about
unions had unintended consequences that
we're still living with like workplace
insurance um you know that that weren't
necessarily designed to hurt us overall
but have have over the years because of
the expense of health care and insurance
companies and where it's led us so it's
not all good but labor has had labor but
unions have had a positive impact on the
american workplace and the most
important thing that i think joe biden
is projecting here is that the american
working family is the thing that keeps
this country going and
and i think americans
gave that proof to themselves again
during the pandemic
when the essential worker quote unquote
that's what they called them the
essential worker um
and really honestly when they called
them essential workers my feeling was at
the time every single one of those
people that were deemed essential
workers should have been able to
unionize it doesn't matter what state
they were in because they were essential
right um but give us your take on his
speech yesterday but also the trap that
he's setting the political trap here
because remember we politicize
everything here and i think joe biden is
setting a very very very crucial
political trap right before this midterm
when he says this morning maca
republicans don't understand that wall
street didn't build this country the
american working families have what's
your take
absolutely fact 100
you know
elon musk is [ __ ] without everybody in
this factory pumping out teslas
uh you just it's a it's a forgotten
just
a basic
basic fact of reality that nothing gets
done no one makes a dime unless
somebody's out there working and labor
day is a celebration of the worker and
joe joe biden did an amazing job with
that speech he really did and you know
the whole greed is good generation that
came along from reagan in the 80s it
totally screwed up the mindset in this
country for the last 40 years you know
everybody
thinks that they're going to be
wealthy one day everybody wants to think
that you know everybody wants to think
and it's not until you get old and wise
that you realize
that no the mass vast majority of us are
just going to work a job we're going to
take care of our families and do the
best we can for each other and yeah we
need to have upward mobility as a
possibility
but that doesn't mean ignore the workers
that doesn't mean ignore the people that
are getting it done on a day-to-day
basis
you know i mean they
everywhere you look
every billionaire out there
they didn't get rich off themselves you
know
they all had an army of people even mark
zuckerberg and and
all of these dot-com billionaires that
we like to think did it all by
themselves didn't
facebook doesn't exist if mark
zuckerberg didn't put a team together to
get it
out to the people he didn't do it alone
he may have come up with a concept and
written the original code and god bless
him i'm glad he's rich
you know i'm glad this is a country
where you can get rich
but damn it man everybody makes it on
the back of a worker
it's a worker that does it and the fact
that we've gotten away from unions so
much is why we're in so much trouble
today because i lost
well and i was gonna say i think i think
there's no uh other president in history
and you can tell me what your view is
this republican democrat there's no
president that has been pro-union than
joe biden more pro-union than joe biden
and i think it's the reason why unions
are getting more and more popular is
because he's willing to lean into this
idea that the american worker is the
backbone
well and you know it's it's exactly yeah
i i
yeah i think it was a great speech but
but that's not the magic of joe biden
joe biden comes from the senate
he's quiet
he is behind the scenes he he's got pete
booty judge out there busting his ass
you know and and the rest of his
administration busting their ass on a
daily basis
very quietly
working for the american people working
for workers that's what makes joe biden
the freaking magic man right now why his
agenda is so amazing is because it it's
because it's he's not a donald frickin
trump who needs validation daily he's a
grown-ass man that knows it's a job
and he's doing the job and republicans
just don't know what to do with it
because they're out there screaming
looking for that guy to fight against
and joe biden's like you know hey
i got work to do go go be stupid it's
like like like he told the guy everybody
has the right to be an idiot so you go
be your idiot i'm going to go ahead and
get this passed right right we're going
to work hard if you want to be an idiot
be an idiot but if you want to work hard
speaking of idiots you got some
information here and i'm going to bring
in gabe sanchez hey gabriel i thought
that i i honestly thought it was going
to be speaking of idiots here's my code
no no no no no no no no no no no well i
mean hey if that's the way you feel i
don't know what you're predicting no
here's what i'm here's what i'm going to
say you guys have done some research
here in texas paul
you're on to a story here about these
christian nationalists and that that's
what i wanted those are the idiots i
wanted to get to not speaking of a idiot
idiots yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay okay
so texas paul you have this story that
is that is ongoing and
it seems like they're using a crazy
strategy here um to really push this
christian nationalism
crazy like a fox crazy like a fox and
you have to let's start out with the
differentiation right there's a
christian and then there's a christian
nationalist
a christian
is
you know a real christian that follows
the teachings of jesus christ is by
definition
a wonderful person that's not who we're
talking about here we are talking about
the manipulators the people in the
christian fascist
christian nationalist movement these are
politicians these are lawyers you know
the old saying that satan is going gonna
come wrapped in a flag and and uh
holding a bible
these are it i swear i promise you these
are what i'm talking about is operation
blitz it used to be called operation
blitz up until 2019 where they got
caught and then they rebranded for the
free to the freedom for all movement
then they rebranded again and rebranded
again
and and what it is it's the uh
congressional
uh prayer conference foundation
now everybody started the congressional
prayer found uh
conference or caucus pardon me you know
it's just a bunch of senators get
together and pray right well when they
started a foundation
[ __ ] went downhill fast what they've
done is they've they've
and and blitz is the is the key word
here is that they've come up with a
political strategy
to come up with a three-tier system of
legislation that they want to push
and blitz is the key word here because
they've pushed out almost a thousand
pieces of legislation now and what they
did is they created a network where
these politicians networked with state
politicians and created this group
to push laws into place like here in
texas this is what ties texas to all
this because we've got and then in god
we trust law here
there now what what do you mean in god
we trust law um because i think we've
got some graphics too but tell us about
the in god we trust law because you were
texting me some stuff last night about
this and i i found it interesting
because it sounded like in god we trust
as they were trying to pass a law um to
well you really usurp the constitution
if they want christianity
their christian god in schools so tell
us what the uh in god we trust law is
tell us what they did in texas with this
thing what the in god we trust laws are
is
it's a law that says if someone presents
a school district with a poster that
says in god we trust on it which after
1954
44 56 is our name is our national motto
they were right it's not original it's
not original it was they they replaced e
pluribus
one for many the whole united part of
the united states with in god we trust
so what they
passed was a law that says that if
somebody prevents a school a school
district presents a school district with
a poster that says in god we trust and
has the national flag on it and the
state flag on it
these school districts have to frame it
and then
place it prominently
within a school so that people can see
it
and when
so you're saying anyone anyone out there
can go to a school district they can
present a poster
essentially that has the words in god we
trust on it the american flag and the
texas flag and now that school has to
spend money and time
to to now present that in their
buildings is that what you're saying and
hang it
okay so so why is this so important to
this prayer caucus then and why is this
their strategy because it sounds like to
me that this just is more christian
crying but you're saying it's not just
christian crying that there's a strategy
here well it's not crime it's not
christian crime see that's the thing no
crying crying
whining
see here's the thing
this is the goal of these this that's
that's a what they call a tier one law
okay
that is a law that's low-hanging fruit
easy it's the national motto
so
they passed these laws and by the way
they modified it now to where it can
only be one per school because somebody
printed one in arabic
and presented it and that wasn't going
to fly oh yeah no they they modified the
law
they weren't talking about that god oh
no
my god only god
right yeah and
what you're saying is
what you're saying is if they get just
one as long as the christians are first
that's it
yeah
and and like i said they presented one
with a rainbow flag but that's not
important what's important is
they they change the law to where it's
you've only got
one per school okay so but the point of
this is
is to get somebody to object to it
see
they don't consider this a win
because nobody's fighting it
really you got this one guy in florida
printing out these weird ones but no
nobody else cares it's it's the national
motto but if they can get somebody to
object to it
they've established an entire
network
to put a microphone in in somebody's
face and get somebody objecting to this
they've got an entire network to push
this out to churches
and tell christians see
they don't believe in god
they're they're not you they're not like
you they don't they they hate
christianity they
it's the opposition to these bills that
they're looking for right and this tier
one bill is designed to be a
uh wet the whistle
okay it is to get the the legislation
moving a little success get this done
then they move to a two tier two bill
which is a little bit more offensive
it's a doctor doesn't have to do
anything that offends them
you know a hobby lobby doesn't have to
do anything that offends their religious
beliefs that's a tier two bill which is
a little bit riskier it's not again you
know it it pushing up against the law
now
then come the tier three bills which
they've passed here in texas
which is
you've heard about the crisis we've had
with
our foster care system
children dying children being pushed
into prostitution
all kinds of horrific things happening
in our foster care system well our
foster care system also has a law that
says anybody that works in the foster
care system can apply
their religious beliefs as a litmus test
to anybody that takes in
a child
so if you're a nice atheist couple
and you're capable of caring for a child
and the person that gets your case
happens to be some radical
they can say oh no no no no
better better that this child stay in
foster care than get subjected to your
atheism
wait wait so what you're saying is
is is that in texas right now that if if
a if a foster child is going to be
paired with with a parent with a family
that they can be
raised and have stability and community
you're saying
what you're saying here is that that the
the actual representative of the state
can say no because you're not you're not
the proper religion that i want you to
be as as the as the state represented is
that what you're saying
yeah and that's horrific right
right the goal of that law
is to make you tony
me
and anybody else push against that law
to say it's not right to speak out
against it to have a to have a woke-ism
or whatever they call it right because
there is old if like if you you ask
james carville you ask any political
strategist
why do people vote
right they don't vote to say thank you
they vote to say [ __ ] you right against
them and if they can take this back to
the churches which there's gabe and i
were talking about this there's an
entire network every time one of these
laws somebody pushes back against it
they run it back to these churches and
blow it out to their to to to
all of their
members
yeah is that the map there yeah here's
the map this is the america prayer
caucus network so this is this is their
this is the thing you're talking about
paul where they have a network of
of folks that are that are actually
instituting uh these policies but not
only that they're they're using the
strategy that they're you're talking
about here where they're
you know they're basically using it as a
trap you know i was talking earlier that
that joe biden's set in a trap here and
i think that's what this is because you
got another slide here does this show
how many members
this one this is yeah this is one one of
the the few within the network it's pray
usa and this one if you take the uh the
scroll banner off
yeah yeah let me take the scroll up here
so this is so this is actually something
that texas paul was was chatting with me
this morning about but this actually
tells you you know how many government
leaders are part of this and then how
many of these you know american citizens
are also part of this so it's like you
know keeping a tally of people
so these are people that are members of
this prayer yes they are just people who
who have who have signed the oath of to
this to this id this idea that they're
going to push this stuff is it
no
it's it's worse than that tony they have
weekly
phone calls
where they update people like
our show like we're talking about it
right now they're going to cut excerpts
out of this show
and then they're going to take that
audio and they're going to play it over
a phone call to parishioners
all across the country
and they're going to tony michaels
you're attacking you hate christians
tony yeah oh well you hate christians i
i don't like christian nationalists
that's for sure i mean i think i think
you said it earlier that that there is a
difference between uh christian
nationalism and actual like christianity
people who you know i don't know that
will not be the message in this when we
say his phone call
right right so so you're saying so
you're saying we're going to be the
subject on christians minds this week is
that what you're saying
um
you know i'll i'll tell you that
um
you know setting the trap here with
legislation
but
you know voting against something is
something i preach here i i say it all
the time i believe that is true i really
do believe that the electorate votes no
or votes against something or votes
based on their fear and that's what
you're saying they're doing here is
they're they're setting up a a way
to stoke fear uh and it's the same it's
the same kind of thing they do when they
when they break something you know they
intentionally break a system or they can
potentially break some and then they
they're like oh well we fixed it you
know like
you know they they do this all the time
so this is their mo
um what's this blitz thing what's this
blitz graphic that you have here what
what is this here
the that is the key word is to come from
so
many directions
that and and they were actually
publishing
the
the playbook
so that they could pass it out to
pastors and each of their state
legislators and and
members of congress
they could pass out so that you notice
that republicans are always on one
talking point
this was that
this was that this is this where the
marjory taylor green talk is coming from
exactly the watchman on the wall the
watchman on the wall that's from this
and what
it's just really just the sad and i want
to reach out to christians when i say
this
if you're a christian and you hear this
the democratic party
is the
am i my brother's keeper party right
we
push legislation
for health care to fund school lunches
and that's what i want to get into for
just a second won't take but a second
this is the kind of manipulation you're
up against they want you angry
but they don't want to do [ __ ] about
what you believe
school lunches are republicans tony let
me ask you a question just a generic
question real quick are republicans for
or against school lunches funding school
lunches against it
[ __ ] and i can prove it okay i can
prove it they give lip service to being
anti-entitlement right
right but they quietly passed a law
through this
network to give
religious schools title ix exemptions oh
so you're saying
they're very strategic about their
social their social rights
they get usda funding at christian
schools if a church has a school it gets
funding from the usda like a public
school
to fund their school lunch programs
you and if you notice when they oppose
that school lunch program they can
filibuster anything in the world i mean
they can get the votes to anything but
that one they just can't seem to find
the votes to filibuster
why it's a revenue stream
from the government and we democrats
being our you know am i my brother's
keeper party
we're like hell yeah feed kids it
doesn't matter if they're in public
schools or private schools let's do this
so it was a bipartisan bill
to get to create this title ix exemption
well yeah because there's no there's no
way that the democrats in this country
are gonna are going to appear to not be
for children eating i mean there's no
way
they jump here right it's who we are
right they're not going to let you well
because honestly i think one of the best
things that came out of the coronavirus
package is that children didn't have to
worry about paying for lunch and neither
did parents
when it came to schools we just did the
thing that we should do with education
and feed children like that's part of
education and i know it sounds weird and
some people like oh that's just not how
it happened when i was a kid yeah that's
because we had our head up our ass and
we didn't realize that that feeding
children feel food is good for their
education and democrats are for that so
what you're saying is so we're saying is
democrats across the border for
the school lunch republicans are very
selective about it
i mean that's that seems to be their
nature the other thing too though is
like i don't know how much accounting or
oversight uh goes into this
but
the fact that they're willing to take
money right the big question in my mind
is how much money is actually being used
right because we know republicans
love to cut corners love to cut costs so
they can increase profits on their
margins so the next thing that i wonder
and i don't have the answer for it but
the next thing i wonder is
how much of that funding for school
lunches
is actually being used for
nutritious meals and lunches and not
just saying okay here's something that
is like bare minimum of what a human can
can die like ingest and the rest of the
money goes toward our program to either
combat
the food program or use it for other
anti-democratic
uh
yeah yeah right let me scare the [ __ ]
out of you gabe and answer that question
there is i last sunday i did a show
where i talked about the television case
that is coming to the supreme court
it is a million-ton freight train
heading right at us and we're tied to
the tracks and it's going
to happen
where where's this case this is the one
from south carolina indiana indiana
okay because i know there's another one
in south carolina that's coming at you i
wasn't sure what's what's this title 40
title 42 usc co us code 1983
is the statute used if say what gabe is
talking about this school didn't use
the funding that they received from the
usda to to pay for lunches say they
built a big ass
gold cross out front instead
a family member
that attends that school could say hey
you're violating my rights you you took
money to feed my kid and you didn't feed
my kid
right and they could sue
and that was the oversight
when they the television case came
forward
the judge in that case the federal judge
said you don't have standing to sue
this is a this is a government matter
you have no standing
they appealed it
and the appeals court remanded it back
and said hold the trial the judge said
no i'm not going to hold the trial he
appealed the appeal
and the supreme court quietly stuck it
on their shadow docket
they took the case a case that has never
been tried they took the case
so so what what is this what is the what
is the sides of the case here and what
is the pending or the pending result
that they're looking for because
someone's looking for a result here
right that means that
if the federal government gives the
state money for a road or for
in this case it was to through medicaid
uh to to care for an elderly person the
the state-owned
uh
facility
did you know they the wife sued that
they didn't do a good job that they
they viola they kept him medicated
constantly and in other words in other
words the government gave the facility
money and they didn't do with that money
what they were supposed to do because
they didn't give her spouse care is that
what is that the crux of it okay that's
the gist of the case okay
but when they say you don't have
standing
there goes the oversight because
this statute
you know is something that goes all the
way back to scalia i hated that son of a
[ __ ] but it goes all the way back to
scalia and and and all of the
conservative justice on the on the
supreme court have wanted to gut
1983
title 42 usc 1983 because it is
oversight for what states have to do
with money given to them by the federal
government so that's essentially
no sorry continue
no go ahead i was just going to ask so
does that now create precedent for any
state
entity that takes get federal funding to
say you gave us the money and we did
what we wanted with it and you can't say
anything about it
it's a free-for-all what it means is
what it means is the federal government
will have to a
stop giving states money
which is what they really want because
the billionaires don't want to pay taxes
right or or create a massive
massive infrastructure larger than the
irs and the justice department combined
to chase
every dollar down to every school
every project every you know medicaid
program every everything to oversee it
this sounds like a trap
yeah it sounds like a trend because
they're going to say oh big government i
mean jesus christ they they announced
that over the next five years they're
going to hire irs agents because 20 000
when they're retiring we have 30 000
less than we need and we really need
more to to do the work that the agency
is doing that well the work that they're
not doing like you said earlier when we
were talking about labor like the only
way that [ __ ] actually gets done is
humans and americans citizens workers
actually do the [ __ ] work like big
government isn't just this big building
that we keep adding on to
the problem is is when you have
regulation like this and they set this
up this way you have to have bureaucracy
to make sure the taxpayers money is
going where they want right and
republicans don't get it twisted they
love big government they love the bigger
the government gets the more they can
demonize it the more they can get people
scared of it the more they can actually
make sure make sure that their
constituents vote in that fear so tell
me what does this supreme court case
have to do with this prayer caucus what
do you see that it these these two
things are connected
see let's let's tie it together so
everybody can understand it okay
you have this caucus
this this organization isn't it of of
politicians and lawyers that
is tied in churches
to feed specific information they pass
these laws
any time a real win for them is to when
a law doesn't pass they've proposed
almost a thousand they've passed
somewhere around 30. of these laws
every loss they take back to the
churches to enrage their parishioners
and say we on the left are anti-god
then quietly what they do is work with
us
to do
god's work
am i my brother just the entitlement
right get the entitlement and it feels
like i'm throwing a plate of spaghetti
at you right
that was the point that's why they
called it project
blitz it was to come at so many angles
so many different directions that it was
difficult to fight against
it was difficult to coalesce anybody to
resist any of it and what it boils down
to is after the television case
not only are they going to have revenue
coming out of the government because
they've quietly been working you know on
programs like we just mentioned
but they're also going to have an
enraged voter base who who you know tony
as you mentioned in our conversation
after row a lot of church people said
whoa
wait a minute
you're going way too far right well
they're using this program to re-enrage
them so that they show up at the polls
because what because what you're saying
there is that they may not they may not
show up to vote for manga republicans
because of roe they may abstain but the
churches may be able to get them engaged
on a different issue other than abortion
right because that's their aim here this
really smells and i um and i know
i know it stinks to high heaven this
really smells like steve bannon and that
stinks like [ __ ] to be quite honest does
this does this i mean where where does
peter thiel
and steve bannon and some of these other
[ __ ] fall in on this because it really
smells like it just doesn't have to do
with churches and christianity that
they're using that infrastructure to
really push this well they're just i
mean they're just using it to keep
people you know like texas paul said
there's using it to keep people enraged
but the other thing too is that you what
you mentioned i thought was interesting
they've introduced or proposed a
thousand they've only passed 30. but i
would you know if i was a wait wait a
thousand bills
that's what he said it's right at a
thousand now right at a thousand but
they've only passed 30. so if i had to
[ __ ] if i had to use that
uh imagine right if i had to put a bet
down on this
i would say that they intentionally put
out bills that are just
random gibberish
not anything of value but they go to
their parish they go to their caucus
their their foundation and they say look
we went forward and we tried to pass
this bill now no one of course in that
in that parish or their congregation or
what have you was ever going to read
that [ __ ] [ __ ] but they tell them
look we proposed this bill about xyz
about how the democrats and the left are
trying to take this away from us and we
as as you know god-fearing christians
want to stop establish this right for us
i guarantee there's probably
500 of those thousand bills that are
complete [ __ ] but are just used as a
talking point yeah we submitted it like
it's on the docket or whatever and of
course when the judge gets like this
makes no sense it's not there and then
they say okay cool yeah we'll just leave
right but they're able to use that as
fodder and fuel to say look we're
fighting for you but they just won't let
us do it it's this we need to make sure
that we have the elected officials in
the state district level
to make sure that we actually are able
to pass these you know tier two tier
three whatever it might be type of loss
so anyway that's what i that's what i
think and i have no idea if that's true
but i would imagine
they're you know intentionally
just like they're doing with the school
lunches they're intentionally injecting
you know frivolous cases or frivolous
things to propose to the court and then
taking that as a win because they know
they'll lose
you know actually you're absolutely
right on and it's not speculation you
had lee carowan is her name if you want
to google her you can actually pull her
picture up she's a vp now she used to be
the director she's a vp
of uh the cpcf or the you know the
congressional
uh prayer caucus foundation
um
they rebranded project blitz to freedom
for all she got caught in a phone call
saying okay they're on to us so what we
did is we're a step ahead of them we
eliminated prog project blitz so if you
google project blitz right now or if you
go to projectblitz.com which used to be
a website that they ran
to pass information on
it's under construction
there's nothing there
but but how convenient yeah yeah yeah
right they better be
hard hats on because democracy's coming
for him that's all i gotta say
but what you were talking about with
with with bannon i'll do you one better
milo yiannopoulos okay
of course he was a predominant um
talking head with breitbart yeah and
he's pretty big in 2016. yeah well and
you know um to be quite honest bill
maher is the one who destroyed him
and and what happened was um he was
going to get a book deal he was really a
rising star and the reason why is
because he was one of these and i don't
know if i'm saying it correctly but he's
a fanboy he was he claimed to be gay now
he's converted back i mean he had a
husband at the time um he was just a
really right-wing fascist um which he
didn't he didn't portray or he didn't
fit the model but that's what they liked
about him and then bill maher had him on
and people were really upset that bill
maher had him on at the time but bill
maher said
you know sunlight is the best
disinfectant and it absolutely
disinfected him um and he had to totally
rebrand and turn around so is this part
of that rebranding is is this uh prayer
caucus
yeah he's gone from being the milo
yiannopoulos with the painted
fingernails and the jewelry and the i'm
gay and i'm yeah
well and he has died here
because i mean
i mean really honestly
they should do that
he's now if you didn't know it i mean
he's a he has found god
he is a straight christian man now he
found jesus
right well he's working with martial
green right
huh isn't he working with margery taylor
green now
he he's been working with anybody that
will stand on the stage next to him he
is desperate to get his face out there
yeah barger's hailing anybody anybody
and
you know you were talking about bannon
he and bannon tied up together and they
are working within this whole
project blitz freedom for all framework
pushing this [ __ ] out is this the same
kind of thing that they did in
in 2020 and really 2021 with the crt
[ __ ]
i mean is it the same kind of nonsense
where they're going to school boards and
they're yelling and screaming just
queuing on [ __ ] into a microphone
and the school board members are like
look this is a [ __ ] public meeting
this is not a place for your [ __ ]
facebook feed to show up
and and a lot of them were shutting down
meetings they were saying oh they're
silencing us and they were claiming
they're being silenced they weren't
being silenced you just don't have the
right to go into official proceeding and
just say a bunch of garbage that's not a
thing then that's not that's not part of
freedom of speech your freedom of speech
is outside the public proceeding not
inside of it it just and
think about this man
these dumb
idiot q anon
cannot put a sentence together
[ __ ]
that are just stupid as can [ __ ] be
if you listen to them speak
were walking into school board meetings
and all
i mean it didn't matter what state
what you know
all
said the exact
same
thing
yep well yeah because it was this well
some of them it felt like this is where
it originated it felt like to me like
some of them were reading a script that
was given to him through some sort of
thing now a lot of it felt like they
were just reading their facebook feed
but it really did seem like they were
reading a script right like here's what
you're supposed to say here's the things
you're supposed to yell into a
microphone it reminds me a lot of
of sinclair broadcasting and how they
have all of you know i'm sure you've
seen compilations where it's one new
station then a second then a third then
a fourth and they're all saying the
exact same thing and in that same way
they're doing this for you know they're
obviously going in locally and rising up
through the ranks but it's one of those
things where it's like yeah they're just
regurgitating the same thing because
they saw it on facebook or they saw it
here and they're just like
i don't know what i'm talking about
but this person sounds like they know
what they're talking about so i'm just
gonna regurgitate it and then you hear
all this like nonsense is that why it
seems like a grass you know they call it
grassroots but is that why it seems like
that because there's something more
sinister behind this i mean obviously
they have they have an end agenda it's
not like oh well we want to empower
these people that's not what it's about
it's about an end agenda
well that's where steve bannon comes in
you know he's got this
he's got a podcast he's got a talk show
they they get these q-nuts
you know he talks to those people he
gets dirty
he keeps he is the buffer between
the oh my god i am a
a you know
super christian i just want room 219 in
the capitol to so that we can get
together and pray for america you know i
mean he's the buffer between those he's
even got a jesus and a cross behind him
have you ever noticed stains
have you ever yeah he's got a jesus and
a like up on his he's got a jesus and a
cross that's kind of gross but you know
what why do you think he's doing that
right
he is the what ties these these beer
guzzling farting freaks
chewing on freaks hey easy easy on the
beer guzzling murders here
okay i don't want to i don't want to
offend nobody
yeah but tony you're not claiming to be
a paragon of the church my man no no
you're just raising your family doing
the best you're certainly not certainly
not i mean maybe maybe the church of
beer farts but other than that i i don't
i don't claim to be but no no all joking
aside what you're saying is is that
steve bannon is getting these people
together in a space where you have these
crazy conspiracy theory nut bags who are
not who are not christians and really
aren't really clean their entire lives
they haven't been christians it's kind
of like donald trump claiming now to be
a christian like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about you've never been
christian your entire life you never
espoused any kind of belief that would
appear to be christian and and now he's
a christian nationalist right all of a
sudden which it it seems like you're
saying the milo yiannopoulos the steve
bannon's here's a picture of milo here
and i just want to i just want to uh
specify here
he is an intern for marjorie taylor okay
so this is his intern bank he is he is
working his way back up and this is in
turn as the straight
uh fix
yeah yeah well it's maybe you can find a
before picture of what what he what he
did look like in the transformation that
he's made to get into this christian
nationalist movement um because what
you're saying is is that this christian
nationalism number one it's not
christian it's actually nationalism just
like national socialism in germany was
not socialism it was nationalism they're
they're disguising it as something and
the way that they're disguising it is
they're collecting an army of of people
who they're duping by lying to them
because you're saying they may even use
this video right here to lie to these
folks right right they may use this
video to say look at this tony michaels
gabe sanchez dick's ball they're crazy
they're lefties they're the lefties as
ted cruz calls midas touch lefties well
you gotta you gotta play the victim you
gotta you gotta say that they they are
the bully right there's the projection
the hypocrisy you need an enemy if you
have an enemy or a boogie man that says
this person is coming to take away
whatever that you hold you know dear to
your heart
then then you have yourself a great we
have now a face on the wall we have a
target that we can go for it and as long
as we invoke that fear and that outrage
and we can keep them going which is like
what texas paul was talking about
earlier it's like you get those easy
tier one things those are wins great
right but you need something that will
be a forever
kind of problem right you'll never be
able to fix it but if we stay in rage
and you give us money and we do this and
we do that then we can keep fighting
this fight against the left or the deep
state or you know the
the the
satan worshiping
democrats or whatever it might be
well this is where it gets dangerous did
you i you know
i hate to expose myself here you know
i'm i am an old hillbilly i am but i
actually like to educate myself a little
bit
there's a quote from voltaire if you can
get a man to believe
absurdities
you can get him to perform atrocities
and if you can take a christian in this
country
and you can take him and tell him that
the democrats who want to provide health
care that want to provide these school
lunches we're the ones that provide the
funding for it that we're the ones that
want you in a union so that you can get
a good wage we're the ones that want you
to be able to work one job and take care
of your family we're the ones that want
a a
minimum wage that will allow you to
afford an apartment
in most states a minimum wage won't even
get you in an apartment
we we're the ones that want to take
anybody that has the education
i mean i mean the intelligence pardon me
and can make it into college and can and
earn the grades
we want to benefit society
by paying for their education these are
all
christian things these are all the
backbone
the work that jesus said to do
if you can convince christians
that i
am the enemy
you can convince him to commit
atrocities
you can convince him to to raid the
capital on january 6th
you can convince him
that uh
crt
which is of course that's taught in just
a handful of law schools
at
at
you know you've got to be pursuing a
juris doctorate to even get into this
course is somehow being pushed all
through your high school and you can
convince them to join white supremacy
groups you can convince them people that
would normally be
decent human beings going to church
you can fill their heads because you
know we all know what filling the space
is right
and we all know there's only so much
time people have to take information in
and if you can fill that space with this
[ __ ]
and make me the enemy
they will vote they will give
republicans power
so those republicans will use that power
to create a fascist state and the way
they get to a fascist state is by
promising the christians a christian
nationalist state right well because
they believe absurdities that that
brings up a good point because um
convincing someone uh that that isn't
true
and then when it comes to fruition it
seems to be true only only perpetuates
this idea that's why that's why they're
trying really hard like lauren bobert
who is a christian nationalist marjorie
taylor green stephen they keep saying
this is not a democracy it's not a
democracy it never is democracy it's a
republic it's a constitutional republic
we don't have a democracy we don't live
in a democracy and
the audience is probably seeing this out
there in their comments section even
just trolls coming in and saying this
isn't a democracy this isn't a democracy
because what you're saying is is exactly
this
if if the majority of people
who are in your army who are your
supporters don't believe you're a
democracy
when they get their democracy taking
away from them they don't realize it was
taken away because they didn't think
they had one in the first place there
wasn't one so if they don't believe
there was one then they don't have it
taken away from but i guess the the
audience probably wants to know is how
do what do we do paul what do we do
texas paul what the hell do we do then
if we are the people out there we're the
party out there
for the working man for the american
working family if we're the ones that
are going to put our necks on the line
for this legislation to make sure all
children not just children in public
schools but children in parochial
schools and children in general uh get
food get to be fed and we do the things
that we as in as a country see as quote
unquote christian but more moral than
than christian that we're helping our
fellow man you know
what do we do then
to not only do the things that we need
to do to create these policies for more
equity and equality
and liberty in this country but to make
sure we're not feeding into this trap
what do we do is there a messaging thing
that we can do or what do you think
you know it's really really difficult i
had a discussion along these lines with
ben micellas
we were talking about
tendencies on the left and some of the
things that we've really got to
we've got to work on ourselves cleaning
up our own backyard first and
it's in our nature
when we see something that's not right
to speak out
it's in our nature to say hey cut that
[ __ ] out
and we've got to learn to pick our
fights
if they want to put
you know our national motto even if you
don't agree with it being our national
motto in schools
ignore it
just ignore it
don't don't feed the trolls put it that
way right don't give them opposition to
you know we have to pick our fights we
do
so that we can get
christians in this country to hear us
i mean because right now they can't hear
us we're the enemy we're the left we're
the radical left everything that they
write we're the radical left man the
radical left here comes crazy ass
radical paul with his [ __ ] health
care for everybody you know that
socialist communist son of a [ __ ]
god damn you're going to ruin this
country by making sure that people don't
go broke because of a health care bill
because of america
i mean yeah i mean it's it's so damn
stupid if a guy that's laying bricks
breaks his arm you know hey send him to
the hospital get him a cash so he can
come back to work you know i mean that's
just stupid that's just communism right
there right now sounds like it to me
i mean anyways it just
i i think i think the messaging is
important and i think what you're saying
is is that uh
and i i like that you put it don't feed
the trolls starve the trolls because
i've me and gabe have talked about
trolls in our feeds before and i i
honestly don't give them any fodder like
like a lot of times i read their [ __ ] i
actually laugh because some of some
trolls are good but the ones i really
like to laugh at are the horribles yeah
like they don't even know how to troll
well they'll either starve themselves or
someone else you know because this is
this is typically how it goes a troll
will try to attack and then you don't
really acknowledge it
uh and then someone else chimes in to be
like well you're wrong this is [ __ ]
whatever and they go back and forth and
usually how it ends is that troll gets
just
demolished by either one person or many
people
to call them out for their [ __ ] and
then then that troll goes
and they get really mad and then they
block that person that that attacked
them
for calling them out and that's how it
normally goes so you either starve them
or they get so embarrassed that they
retreat and then they don't ever come
back again which i think is funny when
you're looking at a group that's so
triggered by getting called out for
being a fascist right so mean that was
such that it was so mean by president
biden went on the flip of the coin they
immediately call everyone else you know
i'm rubber your glue you know it's like
you're a fascist i'm not a fascist it's
like i quit you didn't fire me you know
it's that type of thing but isn't that
what this is paul i mean yes it's on a
whole another level it's on a
legislative level they're legislative
trolls not twitter trolls or facebook
trolls or or tic tac trolls right this
is a whole nother legislative uh troll
level where we have steve bannon and
here's here's the picture of milo before
my own you not was this is when he was
on bill maher
and then there's the after um so these
are these are
exponentially
more dangerous trolls than the ones that
show up in your in your twitter feed
these are people who are these trolls
are passing legislation but isn't that
what they're doing is is to to to do
this i'm rubber your glue that's exactly
what you're saying when they pass this
legislation
they we go wait a second you can't hang
up a sign that says in god we trust in
this school you can't do that and
they're like oh
and then they yell and scream and then
all their troll army comes and protects
them and and and pounces on it and they
say oh i'm rubber you're glue what
bounces off me sticks to you and then
they pass more legislation and more
legislation because they have this
support behind them even though it's
delusional they still have this support
behind him is that is that what you're
saying is happening in a
and i'll do you one better than that
here in texas instead of fixing the
power grid
instead of dealing with the tragedy that
we just had in uvalde and doing
something about it
instead of that
we're talking about in god we trust
posters
so they totally switched the country if
there isn't
if there isn't anything more [ __ ] sad
than that right and that's the point do
you think that's why beto is doing so
well in texas though is that he's
absolutely getting these distractions
he's going to these communities he's not
holding rallies like beto is not going
to big huge stadiums and having a
hundred thousand people listen to him do
some bit
beto is going and he's taught he stands
on an actual soapbox like i've seen
videos of him standing on a soapbox
in front of dozens of people who are
very interested into what he has to say
and not just sycophants i mean there are
there are better supporters there but
there are people in trump hats and trump
shirts
and there there are some that are
yelling and screaming the greg abbott
supporters and the bull horns but there
are those there are those trump voters
who are sitting there going maybe this
guy isn't so bad maybe i should listen
to what he has to say because it seems
like he could be the next governor i
might want to know what he has to say i
might want to know where he stands yeah
and there and some of them are listening
intently so much so that he's signing
their maga hats i mean so are you saying
that we should take the better model
and and and ignore the the noise and
just talk about our democracy what is
important to us um you know get down
back to bare bones you don't want to go
broke because of a medical bill you want
children to start school at three
instead of five and be safe when they're
in school you don't want children to be
hungry you don't want people not to have
health care mental health care
specifically because we have a huge
problem with that right now of access to
mental health care i mean all these
simple things that communities and
community members want it seems like
beto is laying the groundwork for the
perfect model
to really really make this
this trolling this legislative trolling
really just fall flat on its face if
you're running for office use the betto
model
talk about getting things done if you're
on a show and they ask you one of these
[ __ ] culture war questions
ignore it
don't answer it talk about what you're
doing
if you're in office
follow the biden example
just get [ __ ] done
and when they pull you up in front of a
camera and they want to talk about crt
or they want to talk about in god we
trust or any of these other damn issues
talk about what you're doing
talk about what you're doing this is
what i'm doing for the american people
maga
are an existential threat to our
democracy i'm the president and i will
defend our democracy that's it
well and i think what you do i think
what the people out there the audience
can do is perpetuate these messages and
follow these people that are following
the better model the the bite model and
really play into it lean into your
democracy engage in the ballot engaging
about texas ball i know you stayed
longer than you usually do but what a
great conversation today my pleasure
it's been great tell us tell us where we
can find you tell the audience where you
want them to go i know you're you're
doing some videos over on your youtube
channel too but give us a give us a
shameless plug here
hey you know
every day i'm pumping stuff out on
with the midas media network
they are the midas network they are
doing god's work man they really are
when i say that we are the party of i am
my brother's keeper we are the party of
i am my brother's keeper i am here to
fight for what is right i am here to
fight for your family i'm here to fight
for works what works for you
and that's exactly what midas is doing
and yeah i'm i'm running a little show
every every sunday to counter the sunday
shows because the media has gotten so
bad
um lately that i've just said screw it
i'll run my own sunday show i'm doing it
on my own youtube channel uh about half
hour of comment commentary every every
sunday at paul tx890 or just search the
world texas paul and and hit my youtube
channel as well hit the subscribe button
if you can
we'll we'll we'll put the uh we'll put
the link to your to your youtube channel
also down in the description so after
the show i'll put it in there that way
uh people can find it pretty easy um so
everyone can find your channel with just
a click of the link so again don't miss
texas paul on the midas touch network
and also go follow him over on his
youtube channel so you can catch his
sunday his sunday commentary um and and
don't forget to subscribe here because
every tuesday he comes and joins us and
paul it's getting better and better and
better every tuesday um we're getting
pretty damn good at this uh texas paul
tuesday stuff it seems like can i say
one last thing yeah go ahead
tony you and gabe are running
bar none one of the best podcasts that
have ever been produced
ever you do it daily you bust your asses
to help people
and man i tell you what if people are
not subscribing and coming to watch us
they're out of their damn minds if
you're sitting through [ __ ] on cnn
if you're sitting through [ __ ] on
fox or you're sitting there watching
msnbc try to be polite instead of coming
to tony
and getting the real deal where he'll
tell somebody [ __ ] you
when something's wrong
i don't know what you're doing with your
life i really don't i mean because you
are running one of the best podcasts
ever created and people need to know
that
well we got a damn good show here and we
like to bust down doors and kick ass and
take names and i i do not i do not take
prisoners here
and i know i know with the work the
great work of gabe sanchez the graphic
art and the videos that he produces and
the show that we produce um we are we
are going to be the fastest growing
political commentary show and i i know i
know eventually because there's more and
more audience members that are joining
us every single day so
like texas paul do us a favor subscribe
to our our youtube channel and also
download every single episode on apple
spotify and google and your favorite
directories everywhere but but more than
that stay tuned stay tuned every day
come and get your news because we do the
[ __ ] list roundup we bring on important
guests that are pro-democracy like texas
paul and others and we want to make sure
that we're leaning into democracy not
just for this election but for our
country's future and that is what we are
committed to here doing every single
week day monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific and
tuesday's always a special day for us
because we get the midas mighty favorite
texas ball texas ball thanks for joining
us i can't wait to come back next
tuesday to see what you got for us
hopefully we'll we'll round up
some more crazies and see if we can
round them up you know i'll i'll be
watching too to see if we show up on
this um these christians oh yeah no i'm
curious yeah i want to see if we show up
on this i want to see where we fall so
texas paul thanks for joining us
yeah you have a great day folks no no no
what were you going to say where are we
going
you won't see it it'll be on a private
conversation that nobody gets to hear oh
it'll be on a just they'll just pump it
out to the pastors and the next thing
you know in church on sunday you'll be
hearing about did you hear what that
some [ __ ] said about
i you know it actually you're you're
you're traveling after my heart here
when you say that a bunch of christian
nationalists are going to call me a son
of a [ __ ] oh my god
nothing makes me smile more and more
happy on tuesday than texas paul
reassuring me that a bunch of christian
nationalists are going to make sure that
they know that i'm a son of a [ __ ] and
i'm the son of a [ __ ] in their grill
texas ball thanks for joining us we'll
see you next tuesday tuesday my friend
everyone go follow texas paul on youtube
we'll put it down in the description uh
after the show we'll put it down there
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa
don't delay and get your pardon blanket
today for just 99.99
actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
texas [ __ ] ball baby
laying out the facts
showing you how the right wing is trying
to
control the narrative in this country
texas ball is all over this [ __ ]
he was saying yesterday when i i
messaged him i said what are we going to
talk about tomorrow he's like oh i want
to talk about these christian
nationalists and i got to tell you i
didn't know anything about this stuff
well i knew some things but i chatted
with texas paul this morning before the
show and he sent me some links and i
took a look at it and i was like holy
[ __ ] this is nuts they aren't they are a
little crazy they are crazy a little
crazy slid off their little crazy tony
i mean here's the crazy here's the thing
is that they're using people's
predisposition in in some of these
churches against them that's where all
this cueing on stuff well and a lot of
those people probably don't even know
that too well right sitting there and
you know like i went to catholic grade
school and i can tell you every single
morning you know we said pledge of
allegiance hand down the heart you know
we
went to church every morning 30 minutes
good little americans is that what yeah
good little you know catholic american
but it is one of those things like
especially if you're young and you're
you're involved with something you don't
realize you know uh
if you're part of a group and certain
ideologies or
um politics get entered right you've got
you've got whatever that mega church was
a few months ago that was chanting lock
her up you know like when those things
begin to bleed into
the same you know the
what was supposed to be separate right
separate the separation of church and
state and now it's just like you've got
margie taylor green and lauren boober
and other people saying like it is the
same place
where we house our people for church is
where we house our politics for this for
this government um
but i would say like you know i'm sure a
lot of those people don't even realize
it
that there's some sort of indoctrination
or there is this subliminal kind of
messaging in terms of you got to worry
and fear about this
and then after a certain while you're
like oh [ __ ] yeah you know these things
come out
subconsciously now you're saying them
out loud and you're saying yeah
this policy is [ __ ] or we shouldn't
give these rights to these people or
whatever it might be and you may have
not even believed that to begin with but
you know
enough money and enough
influence in a church might make you
think otherwise right well and and it
goes back to um what we were saying
earlier about
that um
joe biden is doing a great job at
messaging here and really setting the
trap for these maga republicans because
really
texas paul did such a great job there of
describing how these christian
nationalists with steve bannon might
indianapolis marginate the green lauren
bober ted cruz donald trump and and and
and all these and these things
molding them together as maga
republicans and christian nationalists
are becoming one and the same and i
think joe biden is doing a good job of
messaging with him which leads me to
this
um i want to show you this tweet from
joe biden this morning which he's
setting the trap he set the trap last
week for donald trump and donald trump
took the [ __ ] bait yeah took the bait
and went out and gave
one of the most fascist speeches that
he's given
since he he became noticed as a an
actual fascist in this country but um
joe biden is setting the trap for manga
republicans and wall street today so
let's do this let's because we got about
a half an hour here we gotta go through
the tweeties
give me like lightning round shitless
roundup so let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome back to the show you've
reached the part of the show the
shitless roundup will be round up all
the tweets in the tourney trends game um
there's a lot of stuff going on this
morning i want to show you um this story
here it's in forbes uh
i said true social is a fraud no way but
the headline is true social spak
reportedly fails to get uh shareholder
support to extend the deal uh can you
describe um have you read on this and
see what what they're actually what's
going on here so there's a 1.3 billion
dollar cash infusion that the trump
media and technology group uh which
operates to social right because they're
trying to they're trying to merge right
right right which out of the gate this
thing was already shady as [ __ ] you're
talking about the spack in in in general
yeah yeah the the the special purpose
acquisition company which is the dwack
right the digital world acquisition
corporation right so they're supposed to
be this 1.3 billion dollar cash infusion
that was supposed to go in to merge
these things they inked a deal last
october to take
uh trump media and technology group
tmtg
to make them go public
right
and but but it's been put on ice because
that organization
has been under investigation dwac this
digital world acquisition corporation
has been under investigation
uh for civil and criminal probes uh go
figure by the sec which is the
securities exchange commission um so who
would have thought like you said
fraud no way uh that trump tried to
because what they were trying to do here
is this wasn't you know supposed to be
some legitimate deal this was supposed
to way to you know basically in my in my
opinion it's uh fraudulently move around
money
um make one thing
that is a shell really there's nothing
to it
see more valuable than it really is
um and they needed
65 percent of its shareholders to vote
in favor of the proposal to extend its
life by 12 months
for the move to become effective however
uh
way fewer far fewer than those actually
voted in favor now whether those people
wait wait wait wait so what you're
saying is
some sort of democracy is standing in
the way
of these maga these maga idiots well
again by a vote yeah yeah someone or
some people within the digital world or
the shareholders is like uh for many
reasons probably like
the dude trump his name that's on the
company he's being investigated for
violating the espionage act uh this
might not be the best solution ever
because they're failing to pay their
vendors which we already know they only
made three payments and they're behind
on many so who knows the hosting for
truth social and its media and its
content might just go up because right
forge says [ __ ] this [ __ ] so i think the
shareholders are beginning to see
i don't know why it took so long but
they're beginning to see the writing on
the wall which is like hey this guy's
not gonna pay anyone they're gonna go uh
they're gonna go
uh uh broke uh because they don't have
the money uh they're not generating any
revenue through this through through a
deal that we would take on and also the
guy that put his name on it not only
that but they got his name on his own
investigation but then him and donald
trump jr remove themselves so they
looked at this thing like wow well looks
like there's a couple fall guys here
based on them removing themselves
because they got a tip that they were
going to be subpoenaed right so trump
the guy whose name is is on
the company decided to remove himself
right and association
so when you look at those shareholders
they're like
something's not right here so maybe we
shouldn't follow everything because
something smells like something smells
like cow [ __ ] yeah i don't know what it
might i mean if it if it smells like it
and it looks like it then it probably is
might it might have something to do with
devin nunes i don't know when it smells
like cow [ __ ] it might have something to
do with devin nunes i'm just saying but
you know there is there is a saying
going around um that you know uh the the
president of the united states said the
other day um and i i wanna and this is
probably part of this issue here let's
listen no no no no no no no no don't
let him go
he's look everybody's entitled to be an
idiot everybody everybody's entitled to
be an idiot um this is this is brilliant
and it brings me it brings me to
um the tweet that that
the president united states published
this morning it's also it's also the
same
same type of message right different
words but same type of message that he
had during his soul of the nation speech
which was
look
everyone's
entitled to be an idiot and also you
know when he's when he hears someone off
there with a bullet
they're talking he's like look they've
never suffered from good manners or good
etiquette right like these people
are are not uh professional in any way
they are not kind in any way they will
speak over you and try to uh
you know uh drown out your message
and biden's like look yeah first
amendment it's a thing you should you
can do it however if you do something
and you sound like a [ __ ] idiot
that's your problem that's on you i'm
not gonna i am not gonna use my
authority to
to silence the dumb ass [ __ ] you're
about to say so if you want to embarrass
yourself go right ahead but
i'm not gonna stop you you know and so
we've seen that two on two occasions
right now where he's just like walking
around and talking and he's like yeah
[ __ ] you wanna embarrass yourself go
right ahead i don't care you know you
know you know the last couple days
because we posted a video of joe biden
in this speech where he's talking about
that we beat pharma and everyone's in
the thing oh you were you were for the
vaccine you were farming blah blah blah
like and here here it is again
and they're gonna go after normal
average working people because joe biden
is setting the trap he tweets this
morning we understand something that
maca republicans in congress don't
wall street didn't build this country
working people did now this is very
important
i believe that this was not tweeted from
the toilet
i actually believe
certainly it definitely wasn't tweeted
from the toilet at three in the morning
well right but i mean this is a tweet
that he's been planning for some time
right and the reason why they've been
planning this for some time is because
of the words that it says and this is
very important for all the viewers out
there and all the listeners out there to
understand that joe biden is now the
lead on messaging and it's and it's the
lead message that democrats need and
pro-democracy people need to lean into
we've been saying it here for [ __ ]
months we've been saying exactly what
he's saying in this in this tweet for
months
but the first word
we
that is the most
one of the most important parts about
this tweet and i know it sounds trivial
yeah but the reason why this is so
important is because he is he is talking
to the american people who are sick and
[ __ ] tired of manga republicans trump
lodites these fascists telling them what
the [ __ ] they need to think and what
they need to do and he's speaking
directly to them and this message is
going to be a message that not only
resonates with americans from the
president but maga is going to have a
really tough time not bashing workers
just like they did with the student loan
debt
well it's also you know you you bring up
a good point which is we right
collective we write the american people
right we as a collective group or even
the working people you could say right
the difference
in rhetoric
from we
or biden to trump is that biden will use
we right because he understands we're in
this together and we have to fight
through this this problem we have to
work together to to better our country
trump will say i
i understand or i did something or i
take credit or whatever authoritarian it
sounds very authoritarian it sounds like
a guy who doesn't want to take
responsibility which i don't take
responsibility when [ __ ] hits the fan
and goes wrong
but i will take responsibility and take
credit when things go right right you
know so it almost feels like joe biden
is laying out something in this that is
an overall theme the last several months
and and that they've trusted their
message here
it seems like the theme here
is that a
democracy over autocracy that's your
decision here is you either get to have
democracy or you get to have autocracy
and you do not to get to have both and
he's doing a marvelous job of sending
the trap here from maga because folks
we say it every day here politicize the
absolute [ __ ] out of this so when maga
goes on their bashing tour of working
people this week
point it out because we're going to i'm
going to point it out at every [ __ ]
pass
and they think they think it's a win
they think they're owning us by by going
after the working people well those
working people
are the ones who built this country
those working people those blue collar
jobs for the for you know yesterday
biden gave a speech in milwaukee which
we played a clip from which is about
labor day
and and reinvigorating the labor force
in this country helping us you know with
the chips act you know with intel making
us an actual competitor
and an actual uh uh uh
presence
a technology that is ours it's power
technology we invented this technology
we should capitalize on it here is um
here's here's one of these uh manga
republicans
the guy who's never passed anything in
his life
well while being a representative yeah
right and also also talks about real
america when he wouldn't know what real
america was if he watched it molest
someone a student-athlete in a shower
that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] let's listen
uh the dobbs decision what's your what's
your messaging advice to republicans
messaging uh abortion
so here they are they're they're even
cueing it up again you think i'm crazy
sitting here going politicize this this
is how we need to talk about messaging
how do you think they've been winning
all this time because they have always
talked like this they've always talked
like this we have
we have to fight the battle that is to
be fought and here is one scummy piece
of [ __ ] that we definitely need need to
spar with in the political space
listen
we'll lean into it we're the pro-life
party we're going to protect the
sanctity of human life it's almost like
that motherfucker's been listening to my
show lean into it lean in lean into
autocracy
taking away people's rights is what he's
saying right i'm saying lean into
democracy empower the people and he's
saying lean into the opposite
he wants to yeah lean into to
authoritarianism he wants the ability to
work in classrooms
right uh
you know he doesn't represent the
american people he represents himself
and he represents the republican party
which again is anti-american they do not
care or give a [ __ ] about us
and we need to elect people who do and
those people are democrats who deliver i
mean just look at all of the different
legislations that have been passed in
the last two months
under democrats right with the with
you know a 50 50 senate but let's really
call what it is it's 5248 in favor of
republicans right and we are able to do
that right and so now imagine what would
happen or what can happen or what will
happen when this blue wave takes over in
in november because people everyday
people the working force working people
blue collar and so forth are beginning
to see
what republicans are saying and when
what they're saying is what they really
mean right
what what something is um
something on twitter is is trending
seized is trending sorry i don't mean to
switch here but this is they never
worked its way republicans never
understand the the actual okay they just
whenever they use seized it's always
done in a way like oh well this many
pounds of fentanyl were seized and it's
like so they so the border did its job
right
and what do they say now see well here
here is uh aaron posted this just a bit
ago it says ask why folders seized by
the fbi from mar-a-lago that once
contained classified documents i mean
anna abba who was um the bone end of the
week last week says i don't know
then pivots to talking about some mean
oh my god a meme she's on instagram okay
we gotta we gotta watch it holy [ __ ]
we're this is definitely gonna be
another shitty legal take you might want
to go and just pull this one i'm i'm
saying this
this is going to be our it's it's
illegal it's safe to say that that like
god right [ __ ] bone hands let's
listen yeah obviously and then the other
thing too that we can't get past is that
these envelopes most of them were empty
what is that
i don't know i saw this meme that was
very funny
on instagram i believe it was and it
said it's amazing at first it was the
codes to the nuclear weapons
now it's invisible classified documents
um you know it could mean anything i
don't know it could mean that they gave
those documents to nara and to the fbi
prior as we know which
i truly don't know you know what i do
know she's an idiot we have seen that
this was far-reaching oh my god this is
trump's
she is getting her legal strategy from
an instagram meme
what in the [ __ ] is going on how how are
how are these people still even around
how did they make it this is gonna be a
good legal takes as i edit it it's going
to be great but i just want to say like
she starts off she goes i don't know
like i don't know i don't know you know
she goes well look we we it could have
been one of the the documents could have
been one of the documents we gave nara
no
no yeah you would have gave it to it in
the folder because even if even if he
gave the documents without
the folder
they wouldn't be like hey we're still
missing this [ __ ]
right like why is why do you why did you
not get one
also
why were the documents taken out of the
folder in the first place why did you
take them out and then hand them to us
but then later you kept your folders for
these top secret classified right uh
intel documents you kept the folders for
them
like why were they ever separated well
we've talked about this several times
there's only a couple different
scenarios here the imaginary thing is
[ __ ] just ridiculous also those
things those folders if you if anyone
knows what they are they have the the
metal prongs that go right this you
actually actually take the document
and take the document out right it's not
like it falls out on the right on the
ground or anything it's it's secure it's
um secure
crazy yeah well here's the thing
because i'm glad she brought this up
because i've been wanting to talk about
this
um for the last couple days it's just
yesterday today's tuesday so i really
haven't gotten into it yet but i'm glad
i'm glad they're over on newsmax talking
about these empty folders and they're
really worried about it because that's
what it signals to me is that they're
worried they're concerned about these
these empty folders something has
happened because gabe
i can only imagine
one scenario when you know who trump is
i was talking about this earlier there's
this book that was written several years
ago by rick riley
he's a sports writer he's a golfer it
was called commander in cheat and i was
watching a presentation last night of
him giving a little speech about his
book
and he talked about how the president
united president united states at the
time donald trump was cheating in golf
he kicked the ball he'd kick it oh yeah
this sounds familiar so here's the thing
and here's if you just go back and you
know who this [ __ ] scumbag is
he kept saying
at the end of his presidency
he was talking about the russia
documents and the hillary doctors do you
remember what he was saying about that
what he wanted to do he wanted to what
all of them he wanted to he wanted a
full transparency what did he want gabe
he wanted to he wanted
that's right that's right
if we go back to that language and you
go back and you listen to what he was
saying back then about those documents
about russia collusion that he wanted to
declassify them
it really sounds eerily similar to what
they're saying that he's doing now
here's my thought
he wanted to take those [ __ ]
documents that had his name on him that
incriminated him that he wanted to get
revenge on the assets that put him in a
position where he was
colluding with russia and they knew it
the intelligence community knew that
he's a scumbag piece of [ __ ] he's a
[ __ ] traitor and he wanted to collect
up all those documents and someone told
them mr president you can't take those
documents those are classified and he
said well what if i declassify him then
i can take him then i can take him well
what'd he do what'd he do he took
classified documents and he's saying now
that he waved his big mac stained hands
over them to declassify them why do are
we standing around wondering what the
[ __ ] is missing from these folders i'll
tell you what's missing i'll tell you
what the [ __ ] is missing it's the
[ __ ] files the top secret files that
showed donald trump and his campaign his
allies they [ __ ] colluded with russia
and he's a [ __ ] russian asset that's
what those [ __ ] folders are
containing that's what the [ __ ] he
destroyed
that's why the department of justice
sees this as such a threat is because
he's putting in danger not just not just
american soldiers in the american
military and the american intelligence
agency but also people who [ __ ] gave
him up and made sure that the
intelligence agency knew that he was a
goddamn russian asset there is you do
not have to connect the dots with trump
too goddamn hard to understand what he's
doing and if you go back and you look at
those videos where he's talking about
declassifying those documents people
like why is he wanting to do this this
is such a this is such a weird thing why
would he want this type of transparency
no he didn't want transparency he wanted
the ability to steal him
yeah he wanted the ability to steal him
so that he could destroy him the other
thing the other thing that's suspicious
here is that there's a lot of records
missing from the white house for the
january six insurrection there's a lot
of logs missing some other things
missing i would imagine that if someone
was gonna fill up a bunch of boxes to
destroy documents that would incriminate
them or destroy their legacy because
that's ultimately to what he's trying to
protect is this narrative going forward
you know 30 40 years from now that this
[ __ ] was a russian trader yeah
and he was a he [ __ ] tried to
overthrow our government and he was
trying to be dictator that he's
destroying those documents don't give me
any of your [ __ ] about it this is a
conspiracy theory
i'm telling you you do not have to know
him too goddamn much to understand what
his motivations were here
his motivations and why those [ __ ]
folders are empty now i believe that the
that that maybe he's still hanging on to
stuff that's worth value because that's
the other thing we know about trump is
he's willing to sell out anything and
anyone for profit for himself and it's
all about him those missing documents in
those folders
every one of them they're missing
because it's all about him whatever
rhyme or reason but they're missing
because it's all about him and it
benefits him of course i mean like
donald trump has never act it has never
not acted in a selfish matter he has
always done something that will only
benefit him if by collateral damage you
know and you know because i'm sure
somebody even if they're benefiting they
get hurt by it
but
if somebody benefits from it it's just
by happenstance like it's not
intentional he doesn't do it for their
good he does it for his good and if
someone's nearby and they receive a
little bit of it then he's like yeah
what it is what it is
but donald trump is never working for
the collective we right right goes back
to this he's not working
with us he's not working for us he's not
working you know we the people he's
working for me me iii
uh it's only mine trump trump trump you
don't get that trump he wouldn't read
briefings unless it had his name on it
exactly right like
this is the guy that will 100 of the
time
only act in a selfish manner to benefit
himself doesn't care about anyone else
maybe ivanka maybe but
never never never does trump ever do
something that isn't in his own best
entrance and that's the thing that's
going to ultimately [ __ ] him over right
like that's what i feel like
obviously with these documents taking
those things that mention him or might
put him in a dark light or whatever it
might be he takes those things because
he's like well if i have him no one else
can have them and find sure if i'm the
only one that has them which by the way
as the us government i highly doubt we
only have physical copies of documents
we have them backed up and backed up on
secure secure servers in the pentagon
somewhere right so
the idea that he's like i got it it's
like you are really a [ __ ] idiot man
and bonehead [ __ ] bonehead man it
just it absolutely 100
is it doesn't make any sense but that's
the point
that's the point is he doesn't make
sense it's not supposed to be logical
here he it is not logical for a person
to stand on a golf course and right in
front of someone blatantly cheat in
front of them it is not logical that is
not a logical thing someone does
it's not rational
and that's the point is that you don't
have to shoot very far you don't have to
have a very very big imagination to
understand why trump does stuff he is
predictably unpredictable it is it is
i've never
in the six years he's been
you know
destroying our country and destroying
minds in this country i've never once
went oh well that's surprising nope
never been surprised i've been shocked
yeah i'm like oh my god i gave it like i
knew i expected i expected him to do
something that was awful right to the
degree in which he acted i'm like oh boy
that wow okay that definitely exceeded
my expectation
that's gross you're a terrible human
being yeah wow stuck but you know that's
not surprising with these manga
republicans and him being the leader
right um of the maga republicans and
speaking of maca republicans
and this movement we've noticed that uh
cnn has been really been captured by a
right-wing
right-wing fascist it looks like they're
trying to court republicans politico
politico is trying this too and this
model of attracting fox news
um uh like if this is here's the other
thing too like if this is some long game
i mean it is a risky risky bet but if
there is some long game let's say
hypothetically that these places were
trying to add or trying to court
republicans to say look okay we're not
so bad we will we will play to the right
wing uh you know ideologies and policies
that you have there
if and this would probably be a long way
to like
um
kind of
d
or like i don't know what the right term
is like but or like d like you know
remove the indoctrination like you know
kind of uh deprogram
right
it'd be a long it'll be a long [ __ ]
game
but that would be something i'm like oh
are you are you doing it just for money
which i wouldn't doubt but are you doing
it for a long a long-term goal
of trying to bring people over and then
slowly
introduce them to something that is more
middle
and then you know that's something
that's not as far right and i have no
idea i feel like it's a huge risk but
also that's just my theory of like
possibility but i don't know it is a
huge risk it is a huge risk when you're
messing with uh the free press in this
country
um when when you're using profit motives
and audience motives um to to shape to
shape what information you're putting
out there and again we try to support
pro-democracy speech everywhere and i
hope you do too and it's not just about
giving money and again
giving pro-democracy speech monetary um
you know contributions that is great
because it keeps us going like if you
want to support the show here you can
give monetary support but that's not the
only thing you can do you can watch us
on a daily basis you can share us with
your family your friends you can spread
it around social media you can take our
clips and share it um
and again if you want to support us
support that tonymichaelspod.com
or do you use the qr code but it is so
important that people understand what
you're listening to because
uh everyone is kind of turned on cnn
here which here here at uh johnny
michael's podcast we've kind of been
knocking them a bit i mean i mean daniel
dale even daniel dale has been fact
checking our fake our fake little true
social post that we put out before the
other the other thing is you know i
posted about this i think yesterday and
i the question was you know if
ceo
if the cnn ceo is courting republicans
like he's actively said we are going on
this apology tour and we want to bring
them over
and by introducing more republican
right-wing you know kind of
uh voices or articles or you know
whatever
then does cnn not become fake news
anymore why why i don't know i don't
know how they square that circle but
here's the thing here's the thing though
is that
it almost feels like to me this could
really backfire on right wingers and
here's one yeah it's because rupert
murdoch in this country has controlled
the right-wing media
to a certain extent with fox news right
they're kind of the the amplifier right
now the tail has been wagging the dog
since trump with fox news and they've
kind of had to play this game with
tucker carlson and lauren ingram really
going full on fascist but what happens
gabe if cnn uses the old fox model not
the new
the new fox model the old one where
they're just kind of kind of
kind of right wing right they do the
both sides thing what happens when that
audience goes over to cnn and rupert
murdoch loses his empire i mean don't
couldn't it have the opposite effect of
what they're really looking for yeah
where they lose their viewership they
lose their empire as it were um and it
really cracks up this whole fake news
thing i mean i'm i'm not saying that is
the overall strategy and that will work
right what i'm saying is is that
right wingers in general their ideology
most generally
they always take it a step too far and
it always ends up giving them the
opposite result like when they
overturned roe v wade and they were
excited yay we took away americans
rights and americans were like what
you're excited that you're taking away
our rights yeah and we've seen in new
york's 19th in kansas and alaska and i
believe we're going to see in the
midterms democracy
actually engage and you're going to see
the president now rallying behind we and
democracy and rallying behind the people
of america the working-class families
out there and saying hey
stick with me stick with the democrats
because we're getting the [ __ ] done that
you want done right we may not be doing
it as fast or as far as you want but
we're trying our damnedest and if you
give us a shot if you give us a shot i
promise i'll keep working for you and i
think that was the message not only last
week during thursday's speech when he
when he crushed maga republicans but it
was also the speech yesterday when he
continued his tweet today where he's
setting the trap for these maga
republicans to show you exactly who you
are and maybe maybe just maybe that's
what we'll find out with cnn and
politico and all these organizations
taking these right-wing turns
that will see them for who they are
because i really believe just like we
talked about earlier with milo
yiannopoulos daylight is the best
disinfectant we cannot look away we
cannot look away we must know who they
are and what they're saying and what
they want to do they're telling us
they're telling us they're saying it
right out loud and democrats should say
the same thing what they want and what
they're going to do right out loud
everybody don't forget to subscribe to
the tony michaels podcast right here
on youtube you're not going to want to
miss a single episode every single
weekday monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific also
download every single episode on apple
spotify google your favorite directory
while you're there
leave us a review subscribe on your
favorite directory as well and follow us
on the tony michaels pod on twitter
you're not going to want to miss a
single tweety tweet and trendy trend
until tomorrow
same time same place
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speak